hier hinter mir in ca 600 Meter
Entfernung ist der FDP Parteitag und 600
Meter das ist zufälligerweise genau die
Strecke die 2019 neu anschieden in
Deutschland gebaut wurden Sachen gibt
die Not bei der Bahn ist groß zum
Beispiel fehlen aktuell 1500 Lokführer
vielleicht finde ich ja hier vor Ort ein
paar Quereinsteiger die Lust haben bei
der Bahn mit anzupacken und herzlich
willkommen auch ein besonderes
willkommen aus an die Vertreter der
heute-show ich denke da vor allem mein
Fabian Köster und übrigens Rudi
Rentschler der sitzt wieder da drüben
bei den Baden-Württembergern Liebe heute
show
er die Deutsche Bahn will sich rund um
erneuern auch die Ansagen sollen neu
eingesprochen werden und dafür wollen
wir sie
heute müssen wir Ehre für mich aber ich
glaube nicht dass ich da der richtige
Ansage bin der nächste Zug wird
pünktlich ankommen vielleicht eine
Minute vor Fahrplan mich Ankunft da
merkt man dann doch wieder die FDP
bleibt nur Spaßpartei wie geht's ihnen
echt scheiße ja oder ja ja und ich habe
eine Bitte ich würde das gerne mal
machen und wie fühlen sie sich ähm okay
und immer noch gut noch gut aber ich
will mit ihnen über die Deutsche Bahn
reden
das nämlich super wenn er immer eine
Frage stellt und wo man antwortet sagt
er das erzählen sie denn für ein Blech
ist ein gut ne aber bei ihnen stimmt ja
meistens auch muss man dazu sagen ne ich
nehme es mal wieder
konnten sie sich vorstellen Lokführerin
zu werden
als der ist wenn man in einen Bahnsteig
kommt auf ein Bahnsteig und es riecht so
richtig wunderbar nach Urin dann weiß
ich dann sind sie angepisst ne
angekommen aber ich bin jetzt angepisst
ja ich habe den Witz schon verstanden ja
ja genau ich bin sowas von angepisst
könnten Sie sich vorstellen nach ihrer
Zeit in der Politik Lokführer zu werden
ich fürchte nach meiner Zeit in der
Politik mit den weiteren Fortschritten
bei der künstlichen Intelligenz ob es
dann überhaupt noch Lokführer gibt ich
habe ich habe also vorher noch ein
bisschen länger Politik die Menschen bei
der FDP Nerven oder Lokführer werden ist
doch auch egal oder
thank you for travelling des Deutschen
Bahn der Mann wird Lokführer ich weiß
dass es keinen Spaß macht über die Bahn
zu reden aber wir müssen es nur mal tun
die Lage im Netz ist schwieriger als die
der FDP die einzige Lage die noch
Schwierigkeit ist die Lage ist nämlich
im Netz ist schwieriger als jeder FDP
weil völlig überlastet wichtig ist bei
der Aufgabe natürlich Humor ja sie sind
schienbeauftragter braucht man da Humor
auch auf jeden Fall Humor ich möchte
jetzt hier aber auch mal mit Klischees
aufräumen natürlich ist die FDP nicht
nur eine Porsche Partei das sieht man
auch am riesigen Andrang hier am Stand
der Deutschen Bahn
haben sie kurz für mich Zeit
ja klar hätten Sie Lust Lokführer zu
werden
also als kleiner Junge habe ich
natürlich davon geträumt aber ich
verstehe nichts davon und ich habe ja
jetzt eine andere Aufgabe und da bleibt
auch zum umschulen nicht mehr so viel
Zeit anstelle ich lieber eine rechtliche
Frage an Sie ist die Deutsche Bahn in
ihrem aktuellen Zustand ein Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit
nein und vor allen Dingen ist ja wichtig
dass der Verkehrsminister alles in
seiner Macht stehende tut um den Stau um
diesen Investitionsstau der sich darüber
Jahrzehnte aufgetürmt hat jetzt auch
aufzulösen das wäre wichtig denn das
müsste mal jemand sagen Sie haben ja die
Deutsche Bahn zu Chefsache erklärt jetzt
die schlechte Nachricht die schlechte
Nachricht ist weil sie das glaube ich
noch nicht mitbekommen haben sie sind
der Chef der sich jetzt darum kümmern
muss
und deswegen der Bundesverkehrsminister
und kümmert mich natürlich um die um die
Deutsche Bahn wir haben
rekordinvestitionen vor und wir müssen
natürlich jetzt auch sehen dass diese
dieser Netz Zustand den wir haben so
nicht bleiben kann jetzt werden ja im
Haushalt 2023 12 Milliarden für
Bundesfernstraßen ausgegeben und 9
Milliarden für bundesschienenwege ich
habe mir ersten Gag überlegt dazu aber
ich dachte es ist vielleicht lustiger
wenn ihr einfach den Koalitionsvertrag
zitiere wir wollen erheblich mehr
die Schiene als in die Straße und viel
schöner ist es noch wenn sie sich den
letzten
koalitionsausschussbeschluss anschauen
und da steht ja erheblich mehr drin da
steht nämlich die Zahl von 45 Milliarden
drin und auch noch nicht geklärt ist wie
es finanziert werden soll diese Lkw-Maut
reicht ja nicht naja aber wenn sie
alleine die Einnahmen der Lkw-Maut sind
und sie nehmen die Einnahmen der LK
zusätzlich zu dem was da jetzt schon im
Entwurf steht dann haben sie erheblich
mehr was wenn die Schiene investieren
und gleichzeitig tun wir das was man was
wir vor
zu Beginn der Regierungszeit auch
zugesagt haben Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben sei eine gute Nachricht
darf ich noch einen Fakt zum Ende sagen
und zwar habe ich gelesen 2022 wurden 74
km Schiene neu gebaut und 10.000
Kilometer Straße das war der Fakt den
Jahr einfach nur auf dem Weg gehen
wollte und kann ich Ihnen sagen das
wollen wir auch ändern weil wir durch
diesen letzten Beschluss im
Koalitionsausschuss jetzt ein deutliches
beschleunigungskonzept auch für den
Schienenausbau vorgelegt haben trotzdem
letztes Jahr 74 km Schiene 10 000 km
Straße vielen Dank für das Gespräch Herr
scheuer
sehr witzig und wiesen sie noch mal
[Musik]
Kanal da abonniert und ein Like da lasst
Wagenreihung heute in Abmoderation
umgekehrter
zusehen fürs danke